صراع على السلطه في السودان يخشى ان يتحول
الى حرب اكثر دمويه واطول امدا لكن طرفي
الصراع في العاصمه الخرطوم في وضعيتين
متباينتين فالقتال يجري بين مجموعتين
متفاوتتين في العدد والمعدات العسكريه
في تقرير لها رصدت قدرات الطرفين ومدى
امكانيه استمرارهما في القتال لفتره طويله
القوات المسلحه بقياده البرهان تملك اكثر
من 200 الف جندي جيش تقليدي يعرف شوارع
الخرطوم وتضاريسها مدرب على الدفاع عن تلك
المواقع بشكل جيد كما يدعمه سلاح الجو
بتشكيله من طائرات
ومروحيات ومدرعات وصواريخ عدا عن ادارته
لمصنع عسكري يزوده بالذخيره والعربات
المدرعه في الجهه المقابله يتوقع خبراء
عسك ان قوات الدعم السريع شبه العسكريه
تقاتل بما يقرب من اربعين الف مسلح رغم ان
مصادر في الدعم السريع تقول ان عديدها
يقترب من 150 الفا وتعتمد هذه القوات على
تشكيله واسعه من مضادات الطائرات والعربات
المدرعه لكنها بطبيعه الحال لا تمتلك
سلاحا جويا غير ان هناك نقطه لصالح هذه
القوات بحسب
وهي الرواتب المجزيه مقرنه برواتب الجيش
السوداني وبحكم خلفيه تجنيدها كجماعات
مسلحه قبليه في دارفور وعلى حدود تشاد لا
درايه لقسم من عناصر الدعم السريع بتضاريس
العاصمه ولم يسبق ان توغلت فيها كما تتوغل
الان غير انها نجحت في ابتكار مسارات
جديده لتوفير الدعم بالذخيره لابقاء
عناصرها قادرين على خوض معارك استنزاف
طويله لكن يبقى التحدي القائم امام الدعم
السريع هو كيفيه سيطره على العاصمه
الخرطوم وهو امر لم يحدث في التاريخ
القريب من اي حركه خارجه عن الجيش او من
محاولات التمرد المتعدده في السودان وعمر
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات